I got diagnosed with ADHD when I was a
young kid I had an anger issue growing
up and my life just spiraled out of
control when I was 13 when I discovered
drugs and became an addict and ended up
in prison when I was 15 got out
promise I would change my ways find a
new group of friends I think I lasted 20
hours like literally that night right
back at it my mom had called the police
because she had found some kids in my
room and I decided to steal a car and go
on the run and before I stole the car I
had a handgun sitting next to me and I
said to myself that if the cop stop me
I'm just going to pull the gun and let
them take my life when I smashed into
the side of a house went for the gun and
for whatever reason it got stuck wow
that is a powerful story and it's
powerful because I mean it's kind of an
extreme example of how anybody can turn
their life around